Hi! Ms. Coffee Bean and I would
like to discuss something with you:
Natural Language Understanding Benchmarking, or
NLU Benchmarking in short.
Aaah, why should we care?
You can have the best machine
learning algorithm in the world,
but if your data is crap, your
model won’t be much better.
And since our goal is to achieve natural
language understanding – is it though?
Yes, of course it is, how else should my
smart fridge ever truly understand me?
So because we want to achieve NLU, we also need
ways to measure how far we are to getting there.
But according to this position
paper, NLU benchmarking is broken.
So in this video, we are going to discuss:
How NLU benchmarking is conducted nowadays,
why it is broken and what this
paper proposes to do about this.
Of course, all this is sprinkled with a little
bit of Ms. Coffee Bean’s opinion here and there.
We will try to make it clear where it is the case.
NLU Benchmarking. Why is this even a thing?
Don’t laugh, but the way research measures
progress towards machine learning systems
that can understand natural language,
is through tests and benchmarks.
It’s school all over again, but now
the ML models are writing the test.
I don’t know why this procedure is
so hilarious to Ms. Coffee Bean.
Come on, Ms. Coffee Bean, how
else should we go on about it?
We need to measure, to quantify,
and write all of it down.
I mean, imagine a tree in a forest growing
so big, that it achieved NLU. Did it even
achieve NLU if there was no scientist to
measure it and write a paper about it?
Of course not, so here we
are, at the starting point
of this paper: at tests and benchmarks containing
a lot of examples that a model
should get right to achieve NLU.
Collections of data examples, or in
short: benchmark datasets, can be
something like SuperGLUE, containing data from
various tasks that challenge these models.
To give you one example,
let’s take the Word-in-Context
subpart of SuperGLUE probing
for Word Sense Disambiguation.
Here the model reads in two sentences and must
decide whether a word used in both sentences
has the same sense or not. In this example, bed
has a different meaning in the two sentences.
Of course, there are many other tasks, like
reading comprehension, which is also probed
by the SQuAD 2 English reading comprehension
leader board if you have heard of it.
Anyway, the point here is that guess what:
biased models, that are not at all at
NLU-level, are able to solve these benchmarks.
Now… we won’t get into the philosophical
rabbit hole of asking who decides that these
systems are biased and are not at the level of NLU
(although they solve the examples probing for NLU
even better than humans), because it is that
sensitive area where goal posts are either
moved a lot, or people themselves have different
opinions on where the goal post even is.
But let’s formulate the general consensus
like this: Although the models solve these
NLU benchmarks in particular, they do
not seem capable of NLU in general.
They possess the biases specifically required
for these benchmarks, but not for other things.
In other words, these models don’t solve the
task, they only solve the datasets. Taken
from another angle, they solve the examples
for the wrong reasons. Bean: What are the
right reasons? Ms. Coffee Bean, quiet! That’s…
complicated. Maybe something for another video.
Anyway, to counter the
problems of usual benchmarks,
where models are exploiting dataset biases
and spurious correlations left in there,
like when an answer is correlated with a
specific word, benchmarks like DynaBench
are going away from the classical IID
benchmark and goes into adversarial mode
by asking human annotators to try to fool neural
models, or at least a reference neural model.
But as the authors of this paper highlight,
adversarially constructed benchmarks will produce
challenging examples, I mean: they are built
specifically such that models are set up to fail.
But they also argue that, this again,
doesn’t help to produce a better way
of benchmarking NLU, because these example
can be circumvented by producing models that
drop one set of the bad reasons it used to
solve the task without “understanding” it,
and just choose another set of bad reasons that
are not targeted by the adversarial benchmark.
So the point here is, that usual
benchmarks are broken because of biases,
that adversarial benchmarks do not solve
the problem either, so the authors propose
four new criteria that benchmarks should satisfy.
Let’s see what these four criteria are.
We cite: “benchmarks should offer a valid test
of the full set of relevant language phenomena
[Oh god, what does this even mean?], they should
be built around consistently-labeled data [Ms.
Coffee Bean, explain!], they should offer
adequate statistical power [I don't get it.],
and they should disincentivize the use of
systems with potentially harmful biases.”
Oh god, let’s take it slow and
see how the authors break up
each of these points into digestible pieces.
The first criterion is the validity of
the test. This means that if system A
scores higher than the system B, then A should
be better at the task it was tested it at.
Of course, this criterion will be violated by
a system B exploiting biases in the dataset.
The authors go on arguing how naturally-occurring
examples – think about data samples scraped
from the internet –, are not guaranteeing
validity since natural distributions reflect
the biases in the wild, but they also won’t
necessarily tickle out the relevant abilities
for language comprehension from the model,
because answers can be achieved also through
factual knowledge rather than understanding.
Just imagine a reading comprehension task where
the model must extract who the president of the
United States is from a text. Well, it does
not need to if it has memorized this fact.
Okay, Ms. Coffee Bean… But surely examples
generated by experts should do the trick, right?
No. What do you mean, no? Well… Expert-authored
examples have problems too: they are expensive,
that’s sure, and experts are humans too
and will introduce their own selection
bias – of phenomena they are studying,
for example. So expert annotation does
not guarantee broad testing
coverage for model abilities either.
Ok… Ms. Coffee Bean, what
else is there in the paper?
Ahh lastly, crowdsourcing where random
people on the internet construct data.
There is no surprise I guess, that this is broken
too because annotators are conserving energy
(which is just the physicists
way of saying “lazy”),
therefore are generating repetitive, easy cases.
I can speak from own experience here.
I worked with the Visual Dialog dataset
where crowd workers had to create a
dialog given an image and its caption.
By going through the examples, it is clear
how uninspired some annotators were, since
too many examples just talk about the picture
in general and ask if that is in color or not;
instead of focusing more on
what is happening in the image,
which would have been the desired annotation.
Okay, so what would the perfect
test set look like if it were valid?
Well, the authors do not really propose
THE solution, otherwise this wouldn’t be
a position paper, but a paper presenting THE
dataset implementing this solution, right?
But they survey some promising directions where
crowdsourcing is combined with expert annotation;
so where experts are filling in the
gaps that laymen could not fill.
Or by offering bonuses to crowd workers when
they avoid overused words and constructions.
Well, and if everything about the
first criterion isn’t going so well,
wait until you see the second
criterion of reliable annotation.
How many times have you gone through your data
and saw wrong labels? Well, this is either due
to careless mislabelling, or just because
the annotation guidelines were unclear or
underspecified – oh, I know that one –
or annotators themselves cannot agree
on one single label.
And if the benchmark has such
errors, we can see the effect of
super-human performance on benchmarks.
While one human only tries to solve the task
with his own judgement that might not reflect
the judgment of other annotators, models can
pick up the patterns of the most frequent
judgments and herewith surpass
any single human annotator.
The solution to this is careful planning and
testing of the annotation guidelines. Or:
not compressing three annotations into one,
but keeping the annotation distribution there
to analyze how this fits with the
prediction distribution of the model. Cool.
The third criterion is about a benchmark’s
statistical power. The size of the data should be
large and discriminative enough, such that
differences between two model’s quality
can be significantly detected. Fulfilling
this is becoming harder and harder
as the models get better because models
start solving all easy examples correctly.
And when easy examples make up most of the data,
models start to differ only in the long tail
containing only few samples, not delivering
statistical significance. The solution?
It’s simple: get more data. But
well, the reality is expensive,
everything costs, especially when
talking about more difficult data
points. So we see how this becomes
already a field of compromise.
The authors bring up the idea
that maybe we can manage to
formulate each data acquisition effort as
a game where people by playing, annotate
data for free. Isn’t this a cool start-up
idea for anyone ethically okay with this?
And the final and hardest criterion is about
disincentivizing biased models. So we know
that benchmarks are usually not bias free:
they are following natural distributions (which
are biased, reflecting the world as-is: biased).
Crowd-sourced text is also biased,
reflecting the annotator’s bias.
This is of course not news. But the problem of
having these biases in the benchmarks is, that
models have the incentive to be biased too: they
aim to beat the benchmark, so they must have these
biases too, otherwise they would get examples
wrong when applying political correctness to them.
This is of course a huge Pandora Box of
trouble and asks for further research,
because there is no one-size-fits-all solution
for mitigating bias. “This is not a compelling
reason to accept the status quo,”
write the authors – point taken.
An idea of going on about this is to create,
we cite, “additional expert-constructed test
datasets and metrics that each isolate
and measure a specific type of bias”,
next to a primary task that
the model is evaluated on.
For me personally, it was surprising to read that,
we cite: “Even for the SuperGLUE benchmark, which
requires users to compute test set metrics on the
DNC Winogender test set in order to reveal
test set results for any other target task,
a large majority of papers
that report test set numbers
omit this metric and decline to
report potentially unflattering
bias numbers”. Wow, this depends so
much about the mindset of the community…
What, you cynical Ms. Coffee
Bean. You’re not surprised, eh?
It’s time to conclude this. What
have we learned from this paper?
That data, the heart and brains
of our models is important, but
very hard to get it right. Happily, a maturity
in the field of Machine Learning is developing,
where we move from just model
quality, to data quality.
It’s best reflected in HuggingFace, where next to
their model hub, they also work on their datasets
hub. And no, they are not at all involved
in us saying this, we are genuinely excited.
The sad but also thrilling lesson
from this paper is that clearly,
more research is needed on this datasets domain.
If you think you are more into data creation and
model fiddling is not for you, go ahead and make
cool progress for datasets! It is a cool place
just waiting for more smart people to work in.
Ms. Coffee Bean hopes that the benchmark
creation field will become as sexy as new
model architectures like GANs, transformer
versions, etc. in Machine Learning.
Thanks for watching until the end.
Ms. Coffee Bean will let herself out.
Okay, bye!